the north is the oldest and largest of
the Seven Kingdoms but House Stark has
not always held it when bran the Builder
razed Winterfell and founded our line we
were vassals to the Barrow kings who
claimed descent from the first King and
thus dominion over all the first men but
after the long night it was our house
who built the wall and set the Nights
Watch to guard the realms of men whilst
our King sat in his Barrow
my ancestors eventually revolted waging
what Singers call the thousand years war
to free our lands other families joined
us recognizing that the north is a cold
and hard land and needed a king who
served its people before himself
finally the last Barrow King bent the
knee and House Stark became the kings of
winter yet we were kings in name only
four by then the North had fractured
into petty kingdoms and my ancestors
would struggle to unite it again for
thousands of years Roderick Stark
wrestled an Ironborn Lord for Bear
Island and granted it to house Mormont
when he won a younger son of our family
Carlon stark
won his own keep after he put down a
rebellion and founded house Karstark
one of the most powerful in the north
when the manderlys were exiled from the
reach my ancestors shielded them and
gave them a home at the mouth of the
white knife in return for holding the
river against pirates and invaders now
they're one of the wealthiest houses in
the north I'm not so naive to pretend
that the entire North welcome stark rule
the last war King was slain at sea
dragon point along with all his sons and
beasts the last Marsh King died at the
hands of King Ricard stark and house
Reid has held the swamps of the neck
ever since
houses Greenwood towers amber frost none
survived today as more than names in
dusty old books but my ancestors never
wanted to destroy their foes root and M
the umbers of last half and the Glovers
of Deepwood Motte bent the knee and
became loyal vassals of house staff the
red kings of house Bolton will cloaks
made from the skins of stark princes
they played and one of the Bolton's was
even known as the red arm because he
liked to plunge an arm into the bellies
of captive Starks and pluck their
entrails with his bare hand the North
deserved to be wiped clean of them yet
my ancestors spared them after their
defeat because they believed the north
couldn't afford to fight itself any
longer time soon proved them right when
the Andal swept into Westeros they
obliterated all the kingdoms of the
first men except the
each of the southern kingdoms fought the
invaders on its own that the north
fought as one when the Andals tried to
sail up the white knife the manderlys
fell on their ships when the Andals
tried to march an army through the neck
the reeds fell on their soldiers King
fianc dark even sailed his own army to
the Andal homeland for vengeance and
slew hundreds of under warriors when he
returned he planted their heads on
spikes along our coasts a warning to
other would-be conquerors the warning
was heeded for thousands of years until
Aegon the Conqueror the south had
already fallen to Aegon and his dragons
only the North remained my ancestor King
tauren stark marched the north down to
the Trident and beheld avons army larger
than torrents owned by half and the
three dragons circling overhead many
northern bannermen wanted to attack
anyway claiming northern Valley would
carry the day others wanted to fall back
to moat Cailin and make a stand there
but tauren had heard how the armies of
the rock and the reach had burned on the
field of fire and had seen the fires
still glowing beneath the rubble of
Haran ooh
he melt and laid his ancient crown at
Aegon's feet and rosa king no more but
Lord of Winterfell and warden of the
north
some northern is still sneer and my
hands Hester as the king who melt
forgetting that because of Turin they're
alive today to smear their ancestors
didn't leave their burned bones at the
Trident and their twisted swords and
fill a bonds new throne now many say
that House Stark is dead and gone and
house Bolton holds the North but the
North remembers who United it the North
remembers who defended it and the North
remembers who stole it
long ago my ancestors spared the
Bolton's trusting their oath of fealty
I shall correct that mistake even the
north can forget when there's nothing
left to remember
[Music]